شكرا للزميل ابراهيم بدر اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه مفصله نخصص معظمها لتطورات
المشهد السوداني ونبدا بالعناوين
مع دخول هدنه جديده حيز التنفيذ الخرطوم
تشهده هدوءا حذرا واستمرارا في حركه
النزوح
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يكشف عن عجز في
المستشفيات ويشير لوجود 500 جثه جراء
الاشتباكات
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يعلن استئناف
انشطته في السودان ويحذر من ازمه خطيره
للسكان
وفي هذه الساعه ايضا
النقابات الفرنسيه تتوقع مشاركه اكثر من
مليون ونصف المليون شخص في تظاهرات ضد
نظام التقاعد الجديد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بعد ان اعلن طرف النزاع في
السودان الموافقه على اتفاق هدنه جديد
للاغراض الانسانيه لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه
يبقى عدم خرق هذه الهدنه كسابقاتها
اختبارا حقيقيا على جديه الطرفين في تجاوز
الازمه الراهنه وفي ضوء الازمه الانسانيه
الاخذه في التدهور بسرعه في السودان حتى
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
طرفي الصراع في السودان على حمايه
المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه والسماح بممر
امن للفارينه من مناطق القتال وتسهيل
عمليه الاغاثه
حاليا احنا في المنطقه بتاعه المرسى بس
المواطنين السكان في المنطقه
المجاوره بيجي تشيل المويه من هنا مباشره
من النيل شيلوا مويه بتاعه
الجهاز تتحرك فيهم المناطق الصيدليه هناك
كلها تجيبيه وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد
يعني
[موسيقى]
مع دخول الهدنه الجديده حيز التنفيذ يسود
هدوء حذر في السودان فيما نشر الجيش
السوداني لقطات اللقائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان وهو يشرف على سير العمليات
العسكريه من احد مراكز القياده
[موسيقى]
كان الجيش السوداني وافق على تمديد الهدنه
لمده 72 ساعه معلنا ان الموقف العملياتي
مستقر في الخرطوم والوضع هادئ في جميع
الولايات وذلك بعد الموافقه على تمديد
الهدنه مع قوات الدعم السريع لكن الجيش
اضاف انه رصد تحركات لدعم السريع من خارج
العاصمه لتعزيز موقفه على الارض مؤكدا
جاهزيه الجيش لصد اي محاوله للهجوم
السيطره كامله على كل الولايات 17
والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
بخوتوفان غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير اللي هو متغير الاخير الذي تمثل في
اندلاع الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان
يجري احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك
عن طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه
يعني تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما
فيها القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه
وحتى منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس ليس صحيحا
قبل ذلك اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع الموافقه
على تمديد الهدنه الانسانيه لسنتين وسبعين
ساعه بما يسمح بفتح الممرات الانسانيه
وتسير حركه المواطنين والمقيمين وجددت
قوات الدعم السريع في بيان نشرته على
صفحتها الرسميه في تويتر جددت التزامها
الذي وصفته بالصارم بالهدنه الانسانيه
والوقف الكامل لاطلاق النار وقالت انها
تصدت لهجمات متكرره من الجيش خلال ايام
الهدنه
ومن الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد
اسحاق عثمان محمد مرحبا بك معي كيف يجري
تطبيق هذه الهدنه الانسانيه ميدانيا
نعم مرحبا نايف
كم ما ذكرنا من قبل يبدو بان هذه الهدنه
السادسه هي الاكثر حظا من الهدوء الذي
نشهده منذ لحظات الصباح ولكن نايف الكثير
بالذكر ان منطقه بحري
باحيائها المختلفه نحن موجودون الان
الشمال جسر الحلفايه الذي شهد معارك دامها
في اليومين الماضيين ولكن علمنا قبل قليل
من بعض
هناك اشتباكات ايضا ودوي في انفجارات في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم مما يهدد بالدخول هذه
الهده ايضا ربما في الساعات القادمه في
مراحل رباط تقول اكثر توترا لكن الوضع
الان في منطقه بحري باحيائه المختلفه يشهد
هدوءا في الاحوال بصوره واضحه حتى على
مستوى الخدمات الانسانيه كنت قد ذكرت بان
الحافلات التي تقل الناس الى الولايات او
المواطنين من الخرطوم الى الولايات الان
ارى عددها قد زاد وهي بالقرب من جسر
الحلفايه كذلك بعض الاحياء التي انقطع
منها التيار الكهربائي بدا يعود تد
المشكله فقط نايف في مساله المياه وهذه
كما علمنا ايضا جاري الان اصلاح بعض
المحطات التي خرجت من الخدمه مثل محطه
بحري وهي من المحطات الكبيره بطبيعه الحال
جاري الاصلاح الاعطاب لعوده المياه لانها
تمثل هاجسا كبيرا للمواطنين هنا في منطقه
بحري وبالتالي لم يتم رصد اي خرق لهذه
الهدنه منذ منتصف ليله البارحه على الاقل
في الخرطوم بحري حتى الان محمد
قبل في ساعات الصباح الاولى تابعنا بعض
الطائرات التي تحلق في سماء بحري سرعان ما
رده المضادات الارضيه الخاصه بقوات الدعم
السريع هذه الطائرات لاحظنا متى ظهرت هذه
الطائرات تصبح
المشكله اكبر ويتجدد القتال من جديد لكن
حتى هذه اللحظه تظل الامور كما ذكرت قبل
قليل هادئه الناس حركتهما الان اشاهدهم في
الطرقات وفي بعض احياء هذه المدينه بحري
يمارسون حياتهم بصوره طبيعيه المحلات عادت
بعد ان كانت مغلقه وتفتح لساعات محدده
الان اشاهد صيدليات وبعض المحاله التجاريه
بعض
الصغيره على مستوى الاحياء ايضا الان
موجوده وتفتح وتعمل حتى ما زلت الخبز التي
كان يعاني منها المواطن ربما هناك بعض
الانفراج في هذه الجزئيه لان دخل الى
الخدمه بعض المخابز الجديده ربما شعروا من
خلال هذه الهدنه السادسه بالاطمئنان لذلك
عادت بعض المحلات لتفتح ابوابها من جديد
ايضا السؤال كذلك عن انتشار الشرطه في
الاحياء بالقرب ايضا كذلك من المحل
التجاريه
وايضا المرافق الحيويه المهمه هل رصدت اي
منها محمد
عربيه بان هذه العصابات انتشرت بصوره
مزعجه جدا هنا في هذه الاحياء ربما هذا هو
واحد من الاشكاليات الكبيره التي يعاني
منها المواطن هنا في مدينه بحري بالتحديد
مثل ما نشاهد منطقه جسر الفايا هذه
المنطقه بعد ان تم تنشيطها من قبل الجيش
انتشرت فيها هذه العصابات مما استدعى
اهالي الاحياء المحيطه بجسر الحلفايه يعني
التكوين لجان خاصه به اطلقوا عليها اسم
حمايه بالامس ليلا اشتبكت هؤلاء المتفلتين
والمجرمين حتى فروا بعيدا من المنطقه ولكن
يعودون في فتره المساء ويمارسون مسائل
السلب والنهب الكثير من الاسر كثير من
الذين
بجوارنا في حي الحلفايه في هذا الحيه
القريب جدا من الجسر تضرروا لايف
صوره واضحه جدا من هذه الاعمال اعمال
السلب والنهب وبعضهم ربما اصيب من خلال
عمليات الاشتباك التي تتم ما بينه وما بين
هذه العصابات المتفلته هل مشط الجيش
السوداني هذه المنطقه منطقه جسر الحلفايه
بالكامل محمد منذ امس
نعم
واستمرت حتى موعد اذان الظهر
في وقتها بانه تم الاشتباك مع بعض القوات
الفاره من قبل قوات الدعبه السريع تعلم
بان بعد ان دارت معركه الجسر المشهوره جسر
الحلفايه تفرقت بهم السبل اصبحوا
هائبين على وجوههم في احياء منطقه
الحلفايه دون سياراتهم هكذا على ارجلهم
ولكن مسلحين البعض منهم خلع البيتزات
العسكريه ولكن مع عمليات التنشيط
المتواصله التي استمرت لساعات متاخره من
الوقت ام من امس تمكنوا من القبض على بعض
هؤلاء الذين تسربوا داخل الاحياء ودارت
بعض الاشتباكات الخفيفه ولكن الان كما
علمت هما الان في ربطه القوات المسلحه
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل التي نقلتها لنا من الخرطوم
بحري صحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان
في متابعه لعمليات الاجلاء المستمره افاد
مراسل العربيه بوصول سفينه حربيه امريكيه
تقل 318 اشخاص من سته عشره جنسيه قادمه من
السودان الى ميناء جده الاسلامي واضاف
ايضا كذلك انا جده استقبلت 26 سفينه اجلاء
قادمه من السودان حتى الان بالاضافه الى
49 رحله اجلاء جويه من بورتسودان وصلت الى
جده تقل اكثر من
200 شخص كما ستغادر طائره عسكريه هنديه من
جده الى السودان لاجلاء 140 شخصا
ومن جد ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نصفيا
هاني مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه كنت معنا
قبل قليل من امام القطعه العسكريه البحريه
الامريكيه يبدو ايضا كذلك بان البريطانيه
وصلت كذلك الى جده كما نشاهد من خلفك يعني
في حقيقه الامر هي ما زالت القطعه البحريه
الامريكيه تقوم بانزال رعياها ولكن
بالنسبه للبريطانيه هم من الرعايه
بريطانيا والذين قدمت سفارات الدول
والقنصليات الذين نشاهدهم الان
مصطفيين على هذه الجهه وعلى الجانب الرصيف
هنا السفاره او القنصليه البريطانيه هنا
النرويج لدينا استراليا هناك كندا وايضا
قبل قليل شاهدنا ايرلندا وايضا بعض
القنصليات
في اوروبا مثل فرنسا وايضا قنصليه قنصليه
المانيا يعني هؤلاء الرعايه الذين وصلوا
على متن هذه السفينه والذي والتي ايضا
تحدثنا عنها ولكن دعني اعطيك اياه اعطيك
نايفه بالتفصيل والساده المشاهدين على متن
هذه السفينه 113
شخص من الرجال و17 من النساء و78 طفلا اذا
لدينا 113 من الرجال و17 من النساء
وثمانيه وسبعين من الاطفال
متنوعون على سته او متوزعون على سته عشر
جنسيه اعلى الجنسيات هي الامريكيه 105
اشخاص تليها ايضا او اعلى عفوا الجنسيه
وهي الجنسيه السودانيه وخمسه عشر من
السودان تليها الامريكيه بمائه وخمسه
والباقون متوزعون على الالمانيه والفرنسيه
والايرلنديه
والسويديه ايضا وكندا واستراليا وايضا
الهند هناك شخص وايطاليا والفلبين
والجنسيه السوريه فقط واحد ايضا وكذلك
ايضا بعض الدول افريقيا مثل ارتيريا وكذلك
اثيوبيا طبعا ما زالت عمليه الانزال على
متن السفينه وجلاء ايضا الرعايه على متنها
السفينه
نشاهد هذه السيده ايضا الحمد لله على
سلامتك
هذه الرحله الحمدلله رحله كانت متعبه
لكنها نحنا جدا بالنهايه الطيبه هذه
والحمد لله على سلامتك مره اخرى
اذا هذه ايضا سيده من السيدات وهنا ايضا
احد الاشخاص من الرعايه الجنسيه المختلفه
طبعا هم ينتقلون مباشره الى الحافلات
المخصصه لهم والتي تم تخصيصها من قبل
الخارجيه السعوديه والتي سوف تنقلهم الى
المنصات الخاصه باداره الجوازات السعوديه
التي سوف تمنحهم التاشيرات الطارئه حتى
تمكنهم من العبور والدخول وبعد ذلك
مغادرتهم الى
اوطانهم طبعا هذه الباصات تحديدا هي
الباصات المخصصه بالسفاره الامريكيه هناك
بعض الحافلات التي هي خاصه ببعض الرعايه
عمليه الاجلاء ما زالت هنا مستمره ان
نشاهد ايضا هذا الرجل الذي يحمل طفل قد
يبلغ فقط او رديع يبلغ من عمره قرابه
الشهر والنصف هو يحمله في حضن
وهو الان يتم مناقشته مع عنصريه او سافرته
الامريكيه الذي سوف يمكنه من الصعود على
هذه الحافله وبعد ذلك المغادره من جهه
اخرى دعنا ايضا يعني قليلا عن عمليه
الاجداد طبعا السفينه الامريكيه هي لاول
مره تقف على هذا الرصيف وهي الرحله الاولى
لها بالنسبه
لعدد واجمالي السفن التي بلغ عددها سته او
25 سفينه اذا هذه هي السفينه رقم 26 وهي
الوحيده الامريكيه التي تصل بعد اسبوع من
عمليات الاجلاء وخطه الاجلاء التي شاركت
فيها دول عده وكانت تشرف عليها القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وتقود هذه
المهام بالنسبه لاسطول البحري وهناك ايضا
سفن اجنبيه او قطع عسكريه وكذلك تجاريه هي
ما زالت تقوم بعمليه اجراء او اول
الحافلات يقوم بالمغادره الان
اليهود ايضا لهذه السفينه وهي سفينه انزال
هي اصلا تستخدم في عمليات انزال وحمل
المركبات العسكريه وكذلك الجنود الا ان
الوضع الان بالنسبه لما يحدث في السودان
فقد قامت هذه السفينه الامريكيه بالمشاركه
مع بعض ما باقي القطع البحريه لتصل في بعد
اسبوع على الرصيف رقم سته واربعين او سبعه
واربعين تحديدا هنا على رصيف ميناء جده
الاسلامي طبعا هناك مراحل داخل السفينه
كما نشاهدها وهناك ايضا عمليه تتاخر بعض
الوقت من قبل
المنظمين في داخل السفينه الامريكيه لنزول
وكذلك وصول ال ال الرعايه وهذه واحده ايضا
في من عمليات الانزال او نزال الركاب وهو
يبدو انه شخص مصاب يحمله عدد من الجنود
السعوديين وكذلك بجانبه الجنود الامريكي
على هذه الصوره التي نقلتها لنا من ميناء
جده مراسل العربيه هاني شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس دائره الاعلام في حزب الامه
القومي السوداني مصباح احمد ان المبادره
السعوديه
الامريكيه جاءت مفصله واضاف ايضا كذلك
للعربيه ان المبادره تتضمن ثلاث مراحل
مهمه لوقف النار والانتهاء بعمليه سياسيه
تفضي الى تاسيس حكم مدني
ما هو مهم في هذه المبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه انها جاءت مفصله برؤيه هذه
الرؤيه تحمل ثلاثه مراحل مرحله الاولى هي
مرحله الحوار حول وقف اطلاق النار وتحديد
اليات المراقبه ثم الانتقال الى الحوار
حول القضايا العالقه التي تنهي الخلاف
وتنتقل بنا الى
معالجه النقاط الخلاف وفقا لما توقف في
العمليه السياسيه بدمج القوات الدمج
الساعات دمج الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه
واستكمال هذه الترتيبات ثم الانتقال الى
مرحله العمليه السياسيه تفضي الى تاسيس
الحكم المدني
وخروج المؤسسه العسكريه بالكامل عن معادله
الحكم والسياسي نحن نسعى مبدئيا الان الهم
الاساسي بالنسبه لنا هو ان توقف هذه الحرب
اولا
تظاهر العشرات امام البيت الابيض في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن لمطالبه السلطات
الامريكيه بالتدخل لوقف القتال في السودان
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من اوستن ينضم الينا الاكاديمي والباحث
السياسيه الشفيع محمد عثمان سيد الشفيع
مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه اريد اولا ان
اسال عن هذه المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
يعني هي توصف بانها جاءت مفصله على الوضع
السوداني الحالي برايك ما الذي قدمته هذه
المبادره حتى اللحظه ما الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه لمعالجه القضايا الخلفيه بين طرفي
الازمه وبعد ذلك الانتقال الى المراحل
الاخرى
تحياتي لك اخي الفاضل وللقناتك الموقره
الواقع انا على اطلاعي بهذه المبادره
وافتكر انه قوه المبادره تكمن في انها
تتعاطى مع المشكله مشكله الدوله السودانيه
وليست مشكله
اطراف النزاع المبادره قوتها تكمن في انها
عاليه اشكالات هيكليه منهجيه في الدوله
السودانيه تحدثت عما اسمته
دمج قوات الدعم السريع وان كان انا اراها
يعني عمليه الدمج هذه لابد ان تتم وفق
معايير محدده الواقع ان الانتساب للمؤسسه
العسكريه السودانيه يقطع لشروط محدده من
تنطبق عليه هذه الشروط ينبغي ان
يضم الى المؤسسه العسكريه
المبادره ايضا تحدثت عما عما اسمته خروج
العسكريين من المشهد النهائيا وهذا مصدر
هو اضافي لهذه المبادره بواقع ان
العسكريين الان هم اس المشكله وبالتالي لا
ينبغي ان يكونوا جزءا من الحل هذه
المبادره انا ادعمها من واقع انها تحقن
الدماء من واقع انها تحل المشكله في سياق
سياسي يعالج كليات القضايا السودانيه وليس
جزئياتها الان مع تمديد لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه يعني نحن دخلنا في هدنه سادسه
جديده يعني عنوانها حتى الان هو التزام كل
الاطراف بهذه الهدنه فهل يمكن الحديث بان
المرحله الاولى من هذه المبادره تسير
باتجاه الطريق الصحيح
وبان كذلك ايضا يعني لم يتبقى من هذه
المرحله الا تحديد اليات المراقبه وهذه
يمكن التفاهم فيها مع الاطراف ان التزمت
فعلا بوقف خلال ما تبقى من هذه الهدنه وهو
الواقع ان هذه الهدنه السادسه هي الى الان
الاكثر صمودا ليست بواقع اي شيء انما
بواقع انها الطرفين قد وصلاه غد واجها
مرحله الواقعيه السياسيه بمعنى انهما على
يقين تام لا يمكن لاحد ان ينتصر عن الاخر
هم الان وصلوا مرحله الانهاك المزدوج لذلك
الان يروا ان التفاوض هو الحل الوحيد لحل
هذه المشكله بواقع انه لا يمكن خلال
الاسبوعين الجيش كان يعتقد ان هذه معركه
يومين او ثلاثه وسوف يستلزم امام الامور
فشل في هذه قوات الدعم السريعه من جانبها
كانت ترى انها باستطاعتها ان تنتصر على
الجيش السوداني وفشلت في هذا الطرفين
وصلوا الى مرحله
الانهاك المزدوج الطرفين الان وصلوا الى
قناعه ان الحوار والتفاوض هو الطريقه
الوحيد امامهم
الانهاكن الاطراف الصراع هل سيقودهم الى
عمليه سياسيه ام سيكون فقط الى التهدئه في
هذه المرحله اعاده يعني ترتيب الصفوف او
تمركز بعض القوات وبعد ذلك العوده مره
اخرى الى عمليه عسكريه اولا لحسمها على
الارض وبعد ذلك الانتقال الى عمليات
دبلوماسيه او الى حوار يكون هناك يعني
اوراق ضغط لدى كل ط من اطراف هذه الازمه
سيد الشفيع هذا احد السيناريوهات المطروحه
الجزء الفاضل نحن نتعامل مع رمال متحركه
الواقع مفتوح على كل الاحتمالات الان
الشاهد امامنا ان هنالك اتجاه عام هنالك
يعني تخفيف في لغه التهديد والعيد من كلا
الطرفين الواضح انهما الان في مرحله
اتزان في مرحله بتاعه وقائع سياسيه محدده
فشلوا فيه تحقيق مصري عسكري فهما الان
امامهم خيار واحد هو التوجه الى الحل
السياسي اذا ما واصلوا وهذا احتمال وارد
ان هنالك ان كل الطرف يحاول ان يدعم موقفه
العسكري يدعم موقفه والتفاوض من خلال
عمليات عسكريه لكن في النهايه هو حتما
سيصل الى مرحله ما في هذا الصراع الى
الوصول الى تسويه ما هذه التسويه نرجو لها
يا عزيزي الفاضل ان تمس ان تكون التسويه
تخص الدوله السودانيه وان وتسويه تصب في
مصلحه الشعب السوداني هذه الحرب الدائره
الان يا اخي الفاضل منذ اليوم الاول انا
قلت مرارا وتكرارا في قناتكم الموقره انها
ليست معركه الشعب السوداني وليست معركه
الدوله السودانيه هذه معركه من اجل سلطه
وموارد وجاه ونفوز معركه الشعب السوداني
يا عزيزي معركه واضحه مهرت بالدماء معركه
الشعب السوداني حول الدوله المدنيه
الديمقراطيه حول وسط سلطه الشعب حول سلطه
الشعب على اراضيه وموارده هؤلاء طرفان
يقاتلون ضد طيب الشعب السوداني وضد مصلحه
الدوله السودانيه طيب سيدي شفيع قبل قليل
يعني تابعت تظاهر العشرات ربما امام البيت
الابيض في واشنطن مطالبه السلطات
الامريكيه بالتدخل هنا اريد السؤال عن
موقف الاداره الامريكيه من هذه الازمه هل
جاء على قدر الازمه السودانيه ام ان بعض
الازمات الداخليه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ربما ايضا حتى كذلك الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه هي من تؤرق الرئيس
بايدن والاداره الامريكيه وبالتالي موضوع
السودان لم ياخذ حقه من الاهتمام او ربما
ايضا حتى من دفع الاداره الامريكيه باي
اتجاه من اتجاهات هذه الازمه لتسويتها او
لتهدئه اطراف الصراع
والواقع ان يعني موقع السودان من الاداره
الامريكيه هو موقع هامشي الى الغايه
الامريكان يتعاملون مع السودان عبر وكلاء
ولو طلق حزب انت المسؤول اعلى مسؤول في
الاداره الامريكيه معني بشان السوداني هو
مساعد وزير الخارجيه للشؤون الافريقيه
وهذا عامل العامل الثاني وهذا منصب هامشي
في الاداره الامريكيه ليس منصب اساسي
مساعد وزير الخارجيه هذا القضيه الثانيه
التي تعقد المشهد السوداني الاداره
الامريكيه ليست متفقه
حول الطاعاتهم عشان السودان هنالك وزاره
الخارجيه لها رؤيه تتعارض مع الاجهزه
الامنيه
والدوره الدوره الامريكي في السودان يعني
بشكل كبير ومؤثر قد انفصل منذ ثمنينات
القرن المنصرم عندما خرجت شركه شيفرون من
قطاع النفط في السودان لم يعد للسودان
مصالح حيويه مع امريكا يا عزيزي الفاضل
امريكا لغتها لغه المصالح وليست لغه
السياسه هم يتحدثون عن المصالح لذلك هذا
هو التعقيد الاساسي لكن مع امريكا بوصفها
ودورها العالمي تحاول ان يعني تؤثر في
الاحداث في السودان بطريقه ما لكن ليست
بطريقه مؤثره لان السودان ليس مؤثر في
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه يا عزيز اشكرك
جزيل الشكر من انضم الينا الاكاديميه
والباحث السياسيه الشفيع محمد عثمان
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه قال المسؤول
الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني اسامه
ابو بكر في تصريحاته للعربيه ان التقديرات
تشير لوجود نحو 500 جثه لقتل الاشتباكات
واضاف ان جثامين قتل الاشتباكات تمثل
مشكله كبرى ما نحتاج للمعينات
الطبيه للذات مختلف المعينات الطبيه
والمستلزمات الطبيه والشحنه القادمه من
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر هي فيها كل
المستلزمات الطبيه حسب الاولويات المطروحه
بحكم انه اللجنه الدوليه القريبه
منذ عشرات السنين في السودان ونعمل مع بعض
سويا لذلك كل الاشياء الجايه في الشحنه دي
هي اشياء عندها اولويه طبعا الشحنه يعني
هي ثمانيه طن/8 الف كيلو يعني وبالتالي
هتحدث انفراج كبير جدا
ابو بكر قال ايضا للعربيه ان المساعدات
الطبيه المرسله من الصليب الاحمر تمثل
انفراجه كبيره للازمه الصحيه في السودان
التي تاثرت بشكل كبير بسبب الاقتتال
الدائري بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع
للمساعدات الحامدين من برنامج الغذاء
العالمي او اي من المؤسسات العالميه اكيد
حتستفيد منها
المواطنين وضحايا النزاع المسلح ودائما
نحن عندنا الشراكات مع كل هذه المنظمات
التابعه للامم المتحده وغيرها في ان هي
بتعتمد على الهلال الاحمر بالذات في توزيع
المساعدات سواء كانت مساعده صحيه او
انسانيه على مستوى السودان فضلا عن
الخرطوم لانه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
يعتمد في عمله اساسا على
متطوعين متخصصين في مجالات مختلفه يبلغ
عددهم نصف مليون متطور في السودان
من جانبه اكد المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه نواحد وستين في المئه من
المؤسسات الصحيه في الخرطوم لا تعمل بسبب
الهجمات العسكريه المباشره كما اوضح ان
هناك
23% من مستشفيات الخرطوم تعمل بنصف طاقتها
بينما تعمل 16% فقط من المستشفيات بكامل
طاقتها
61% من المؤسسات الصحيه العامله في
الخرطوم لا تعمل توقفت عن العمل للاسباب
التي ذكرتها بالاضافه الى الهجمات
العسكريه المباشره والاحتلال العسكري لهذه
المؤسسات وطرد العاملين منها
23% من هذه المستشفيات في الخرطوم تعمل
بشكل جزئي
16% فقط تعمل بكامل طاقتها فهذا هو وضع
المؤسسات الصحيه والنظام الصحي في عموم
السودان ولكن بالاخص في المناطق التي فيها
نزاعات وبلغه الارقام طبعا هناك ما يقارب
من 16 مليون
مواطن سوداني اي ما يمثل ثلث سكان السودان
تحت ما يسمى بالمعونات الانسانيه والتي
للاسف يعني سوف تتوقف بصعوبه النزاعات
الحاصل حاليا في السودان
المنظر قال ايضا ان هناك ضعفا حقيقيا
ومخيفا جدا في النظام الصحيح في السودان
لاسيما نقص التمويل الطبي والامدادات
الطبيه بسبب انعدام الامن وصعوبه الوصول
الى المستشفيات هناك فعلا يعني نقص حقيقي
في الكادر الطبي وخصوصا بعد ظهور هذه
الازمه خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين يعني هناك
نقص في الكادر الطبي وخصوصا الكادر الطبي
المتخصص على سبيل المثال في الجراحه وفي
التقدير هناك نقص في التمويل
الطبي والامدادات الطبيه والمستلزمات
الطبيه خلال هذه الايام بسبب انعدام الامن
وصعوبه الوصول الى المستشفيات هناك نقص في
توفر بعد بعض المستلزمات الاساسيه على
سبيل المثال
الدم ومشتقاته هناك نقص في امدادات
الاكسجين هناك انقطاع متكرر للكهرباء
وكذلك يعني نقص في امدادات المياه نقص
الوقود نقص في امدادات التغذيه للمرضى
والمقيمين في هذه المستشفيات
ومع تفاقم الازمه الصحيه في السودان زادت
المخاوف من كارثه كبيره في توفير الدواء
مع دخول الاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع اسبوعها الثالث
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغ هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليات نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد علينا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من معاناه
المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد الدوائي
الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
وفي هذه الاثناء اعلن برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه عن استئنافي انشطته في السودان
لتقديم المساعدات العاجله في ظل التدهور
الوضع الانساني في البلاد من جهه عقاله
المديره التنفيذيه للبرنامج ساندي ماكين
على حسابها في تويتر ان الازمه الحاليه في
السودان تدفع الملايين الى هويه الجوع ما
ادى لرفع التعليق المؤقت لبرنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في السودان وفي منتصف ابريل
الماضي قال البرنامج انه اوقف مؤقتا جميع
انشطته في السودان بعد مقتل ثلاثه من
موظفي في اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا ويواجه الكثير من السودانيين مصاعب
حقيقيه في ممارسه حياتهم اليوميه بسبب
الاقتتال الدائري في السودان وتاثيره على
حياه السكان بشكل مباشر فيما يواجه عمال
الاجره اليوميه معاناه مع استمرار
الاشتباكات حيث اختفت فرص العمل بسبب
الحرب
تتواصل عمليات الاجلاء في ام درمان ونزوح
السودانيين من مناطقهم الى اخرى امنه مع
دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ فيما يتجه كثيرون
الى بورتسودان من خلال باصات لنقل الركاب
تكلفه الاجره فيها اغلى من المعتاد بسبب
نقص الوقود ويقول الاهالي في ام درمان ان
جل العائلات تتجه الى مواقف الباصات سيرا
على الاقدام بسبب عدم توفر وسائل النقل
الخرطوم للولايات فبرده يعني الحاجه صعبه
شديد يعني اول كلمه شعبي لقيت الدفار
بعشره
دفار اقل تذكره للبيض
يعني باقي التفاصيل حتكون كيف ولا
الباصات لانه عندنا باص
ات حاليا يعني الباصات كلها بتمشي
بورسودان
هنا لو بنفس الحساب
ولا الفوله ولا في زبد ولا مدني الرئيسي
يكافح عشرته الالاف من الرعايه الاجانب
لمغادره السودان في ظل استمرار القتال
العنيف لاكثر من اسبوعين على الرغم من
سلسله الهدنات الهشه حيث تجمعت حشود من
المدنيين في ميناء في ميناء بورتسودان
الذي يعد ملجا نسبيا يتوجه اليه الكثيرون
على امل مغادره البلاد عن طريق البحر
يتجمعون فيه في محاوله لتامين مكان على
متن سفينه المغادره ينتظرون ان يحل دورهم
للفرار من السودان وان اضطرهم للمبيت ليال
قرب الميناء
السودان عايش في لحظه رعب حقيقيه
يعني انا بتكلم عن جثث في الشوارع
شمينا روحت الجثث واحنا جايين من الخرطوم
الضرب القذف يعني بجد السودان في حاله
تعترف حقيقيه
3400 العدد كبير جوا الميناء وبره وعلى
الكورنيش الناس في الارض ارامل اطفال
مسنين مرضى بشكل عام احنا قاعدين هنا في
مكان يعني الله يجزاهم الخير يوفرون اصلا
مكان لكن احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني اغلب
الناس قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين اماكن
بعيده اغلبنا اتيم من الخرطوم
ومعنا من اديس ابابا الكاتب الصحفي عبد
الشكور عبد الصمد سيد عبد الشكور مرحبا بك
معي في هذه الساعه يعني مع هذه الموجات
الكبيره من النزوح
للسودانيين الى دول مجاوره اسال عن الدول
المجاوره للسودان كيف تنظر الى هذا الامر
هل لديها ريبه مما يحدث اليوم او يعني ان
هناك تفهم من قبل هذه الدول للحاله
الانسانيه الموجوده في السودان قبل يعني
ان تفكر في اي شيء اخر
اهلا وسهلا اخي الكريم واهلا بمشاهديكم
الكرام
الاولويه حقيقه هو في للجانب الانساني وكل
الدول المجاوره والعالم كله نشد الطرفين
بضروره وتعديل وقف اطلاق النار والعوده
الى طاوله المفاوضات
لان الثمن الانسان الذي يدفع باهض جدا
مع التركيز مع التركيز على تقديم كل ما
يمكن حقيقه يعني كل الطائرات وكل
وسائل التواصل التي يعني تاتي لجلب رعايه
دول الاجنبيه لو لو يعني احضرت معها دعم
هذا كان ما ينشده السودانيون وهذا الذي
كان من المفترض ان يحدث لكن للاسف هذا لم
يحدث ضروره تقديم الدعم
هناك الكثير من من الحالات الانسانيه يعني
مرضى الكلى هناك يعني عدد يصل الى 12,000
مريض كلا يحتاجون الى مثل هذه الامور
حقيقه تحتاج الى لقته من المنظمات الدوليه
وخاصه لكن كدول المجاوره يعني كما قلت لك
الهويه الاولويه للجانب الانساني مع الحرص
على تقديم ممرات لمن يريد
المغادره
لرعايه دول العالم المختلفه والمحتاجين
الى يعني لظروف انسانيه وصحيه لمغاره درت
السودان السيد عبد الشكور ايضا ايضا ياتي
السؤال اذا سمحت لي بالنسبه لهذه الدول
الاقليميه التي ذكرت بانها يعني تريد
المساعده الانسانيه في المقام الاول لكن
على جانب الاخر هل تخشى هذه الدول من ان
ينتقل هذا الصراع او يمسها باي شكل من
الاشكال ان يكون هناك فوضى اقليميه ان
يمتد الصراع الى هذه الدول كما ذكر الامين
العاملي الامم المتحده وحذر من هذا الخطر
او ان تكون ايضا هناك جماعات مسلحه او
منفلته موجوده اقليميه قد تتدخل لنصره
يعني احد طرفي هذه الازمه كما نقلت طبعا
البريطانيه اليوم
بحديث لهذا الخصوص ياتي الوزراء اتحدث بعد
ساعات من نشوب هذه الازمه وطالب الطرفين
بوقف اطلاق النار
وعرض الوساطه نفس الامر دوله مثل التشاد
معنيه بالشان وهناك تداخل وهناك يعني يعني
اختلاط للمكون
الاسم اللي ما بين الدولتين يعني قامت
باغلاق الحدود
واعلنت انها تدعم الجيش السوداني
بنفس الامر
للحاله في مصر وكل الدول حتى جنوب السودان
يعني الكل يتخوف ان يكون هناك يعني امتداد
لهذه الناس اذا استمرت فبالتالي الحرص على
اطفائها
واخماد هذه
الفتنه
قبل ان تتوسع الكل حريص على ذلك لكن يبدو
كما يعني تدل المؤشرات على يعني
اساسها والسياسيون والقاده في السودان
ليسوا في عجله من امرهم
ويريدون معالجه الامر مع قد يكون هناك ثمن
باهظ لكن
هناك تركيز على
قطع امداد
ثم بعد ذلك التعامل مع الحاله في داخل
الخرطوم
مع هذا الامر اتمنى ان يكون هناك تعديل
يعني بوقف اطلاق النار حتى يعني يقل الثمن
الذي يدفعه اخي الكريم ما هو هذا الثمن
الذي ستدفعه دول الجوار بالنسبه للسودان
ان امتد هذا الصراع لم يتم الالتزام
بالهدن كذلك
المعلنه ان اخذت الامور منحنى ومنعطف خطير
في السودان
اخي الكريم يعني الحدود
السودان دوله كبيره او دوله الاطراف
وهناك حدود مع اثيوبيا حدود تصل الى
الكيلومتر مع مصر 1200 كيلو متر ومع تشد
طويله واطول حدود هي حدود مع جنوب السودان
ونفس الامر في افريقيا الوسطى كل هذه
الحدود بالاضافه الى حدود مع الحدود مع
البحر الاحمر
الكبيره اذا لم يتم التحكم فيها اذا لم
تكن دوله يعني تستطيع تدير العلاقه معها
كل هذه الدول
يعني سيكون هناك يعني تدخل
يعني غير متحكم فيه ويكون هناك حقيقه
المنطقه اصلا تعاني من سيوله امنيه ومن
تهريب للسلاح ومن تهريب للبشر يعني هناك
الكثير من الازمات حتى عسكريه
وسياسيه حدثت يعني منذ
سنتين على الاقل شكرا جزيلا لك من اديس
ابابا الكاتب الصحفي عبد الشكور عبد الصمد
على المشاركه معي في هذه الساعه اذا بين
عمليات النزوح والاجلاء هناك قصص كثيره
يعيشها المتجهون من الخرطوم الى المعابر
حيث تعرض العديد منهم خلال رحله الطريق
لقطاع طرق وعمليات نهب واستغلال من تجار
الحرب نتابع
مسيره شاقه رحله لجوء بدات من هنا من
سوريا الى السودان لجا الى الخرطوم قبل
سنوات هربا من الحرب لينتهي به الحال في
مواجهه حرب اخرى
شاب سوري استقر به الحال بين اهالي ولايه
كسلا تبعد 700 كيلومتر عن معارك الخرطوم
لكن قبل وصوله الى مدينه حلفا عاش قصه
نزوح مضطربه
المعارك كانت على مرمى حجر منه قرر العوده
الى سوريا عبر رحلات اجلاء من بورتسودان
لكن ما كان ينتظره اسوا
في الشارع
سرقت
المسار المائي مئات الالاف يرغبون بالعوده
لكن الطريق الى المعابر ان لم تكن مدروسه
امنيا محفوفه بقطاع الطرق او مفخخه بتجار
حرب تجار بات لا ينقلون النازحين الا
بالاف الدولارات ما جعلهم غنيمه لعمليات
نهب لا تصدها هدى غذاء السالم العربيه
من مدينه بورتسودان ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نزار البقدونس نزار مرحبا بك معي
في هذه الساعه بدايه عن عمليات الاجلاء من
بورتسودان كيف تسير الامور حتى هذه اللحظه
التي رصدته منذ الصباح وحتى الان
لك التحيه وتحيه لكل المشاهدين هذه
العمليات الان تدخل يومها العاشر بدات منذ
الحادي والعشرين من ابريل الماضي عبر
ميناء بورسودان وبدات يوم الثالث والعشرين
من ذات الشهر المنصرم عبر مطار بورسودان
الدولي
حتى الساعات الاولى من صباح هذا اليوم
رفضنا النحو 23
سفينه حربيه وقطعه بحريه وصلت الى ميناء
بورسودان
واقلت اكثر من 11 من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه
وممثلي البعثات الدوليه والعاملين في
الامم المتحده كل هذه الاعداد تم اجلائهم
خلال الايام الماضيه من من بورسودان على
صعيد المتصل ايضا هنالك في الجانب الاخر
في مطار بورسودان الدولي هذا المطار
يستقبل يوميا ما بين 6 الى 8 رحلات جويه
لطائرات
عسكريه ايضا تصل الى مطار بورسودان تقيل
ايضا مئات من الاسر وطالبي
الاجلاء من السودان الى عدد من الوجهات
الدوليه والاقليميه في المنطقه هذه
العمليه الان تمضي كما بدات اعداد مقدره
من السوريين ما زالوا حتى اليوم في مدينه
بورسودان يطالبون السلطات السوريه
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه والامم المتحده
بضروره تسهيل مهام اجراءاتهم وتسهيل
الخروج من الشرق السودان الى عدد من الدول
لكن نؤكد بان هذه العمليات مستمره اليوم
نتوقع وصول سفينتين الى ثلاث سفن قد تصل
في اي لحظه الى ميناء بورسودان الى عدد من
رعايه الدول الاجنبيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر
نزال مراسل العربيه من بورت سودان
[موسيقى]
وقفه لمتابعه ابرز الاخبار الدوليه كشف
قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان الهجمات
المضاده الاوكرانيه طردت قوات الروسيه من
بعض المواقع في باخم شرق البلاد لكن رغم
ذلك اشار الى ان الوضع لا يزال صعبا واكد
قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان وحدات
الروسيه جديده تشمل مظليين ومقاتلين من
مجموعه باجنر يدفع بها باستمرار الى
المعركه على الرغم من تكبدها خسائر فادحه
القائد الاوكراني اضاف ايضا ان روسيا غير
قادره على السيطره على مدينه باخموت
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت بان
قوتها استولت على اربع مناطق في غرب مدينه
باخموت وتاتي تصريحات الدفاع الروسيه مع
تواصل المعارك في باخمت ومحاولات الجيش
للسيطره على المدينه التي تعتبرها روسيا
مفصلا مهما في تغيير مسار المعارك في
اوكرانيا
هذا واعلنت الدفاع الروسيه استهدافها عده
مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش الاوكراني في دونتس
واكد المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات الروسيه قامت بشن غارات على ثلاثه
مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش الاوكراني مضيفا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر بشريه وصلت
الى 60 شخصا
في فرنسا تستعد النقابات لاحياء يوم
تاريخي لعيد العمال تتوقعوا نزول ما يصل
الى مليون ونصف المليون شخص الى الشوارع
لمواصله الاحتجاج رفضا لقانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
وقال الامين العام للاتحاد الديمقراطي
الفرنسي للعمل انهم يتوقعون مشاركه مئات
الالاف من المتظاهرين موضحا ان النقابات
اعدت 300 نقطه تجمع في مختلف انحاء البلاد
لاحياء عيد الاول من مايو من جهتها تتوقع
السلطات نزول نحو 650 الف متظاهر من ضمنهم
ما بين 80 الى 100 الف في باريس وحدها كما
اكدت ان اثني عشر الف عنصر من الشرطه
سينتشرون لضمان الامن
من باريس يلتحق بنا مدير مكتب العربيه في
باريس حسين قنيبر مرحبا بك معي حسين متى
ستبدا اولا هذه التظاهرات هل التقديرات
فعلا تشير الى نزول او الى توقعات نزول
مليون ونصف المليون شخص الى شوارع فرنسا
اهلا بك انا قببات هي التي تتحدث عن هذه
الاعداد اما وزاره الداخليه تحديدا
للاستخبارات الداخليه توقعت النزول ما بين
الف شخص الى الشوارع عبر فرنسا من بينهم
من 80 الى 100 الف في التاريخ وحدها سيكون
هناك حواله ثلاث مئه موكب احتجاجي عبر
فرنسا ستتوزع على مدن باريس واليوم
ومارسيليا
وتولوز ونيس وكان وليل واستراسبور
وبردو وننط
التظاهر المركزيه في العاصمه ستبدا في
ساحه الجمهوريه لكاس دو لاري بيبليك بعد
حوالي ساعتين من الان سنكون في المكان بعد
ساعتين قبيله بدا التظاهره
والنقابات تعتبر انه رغم موافقه المجلس في
الرابع عشر من الشهر الماضي رغم قراره
القاضي باعتبار قانون رفع سن التقاعد من
62 عاما الى 64 عاما غير مخالف للدستور
رغم هذا القرار للمجلس فان النقابات تريد
مواصله تحركها رغم انها لم تشكك علنا
بنزاهه قرار المجلس الدستوري لكنها تعتبر
انه يجب مواصله النضال ضد هذا القانون
قانون دفع السن التقاعد تريد النقابات
لتحرك اليوم ان يكون محاوله لاسقاط قانون
رفع سن التقاعد في الشارع وهذا امر مستبعد
في كل الاحوال تحالف النقابات الثماني
الرئيسيه سيعقد اجتماعا له مساء اليوم
لاتخاذ قرار بمواصله التحرك او عدم
مواصلته حتى الان تحذر مذكره الاستخبارات
الداخليه من انه سيكون هناك من ضمن
المتظاهرين اليوم في باريس وعده مدن
فرنسيه اخرى ما بين الف والف شخص من مثير
الشغب الذين سيحاول بعضهم تحطيم واجهات
محل تجاريه وعرقله سلميه التظاهرات هؤلاء
سيحاولون القيام باعمال شغب واسعه النطاق
كما تحذر مذكره الاستخبارات الداخليه
الفرنسيه اثناء عشر الف عنصر امن بين شرطي
ودركي سيتولون نايف حمايه المشاركين في
التظاهرات من بينهم خمسه الاف في باريس
وحدها هذا اليوم ارادته النقابات يوم تحرك
تاريخي استثنائي ودعت الى مد شعبي رفضا
لقانون رفع سن التقاعد طيب اذا كان هذا
القانون حسين يعني نحن نريد ان نفهم هذه
التفصيله اذا كان هذا القانون لن يتم
اسقاطه لا من قبل الحكومه بعد ان وافق
عليه المجلس الدستوري فلماذا هذه النقابات
ولماذا المتظاهرين ايضا يصرون على النزول
الى الشارع يسرون كذلك ايضا على محاوله
تغيير واقع لن يتغير حسين كما ذكرت حسب
يعني الانباء وحسب ايضا قرار مجلس
الدستوري
عندما يطرح هذا السؤال نايف على المسؤولين
في النقابات الرئيسيه التي تقف خلفها هذه
التحركات فان هؤلاء يقولون ان تحركهم اولا
لا يقتصر على الاحتجاج على قانون رفع سن
التقاعد بل يشمل ايضا المطالبه بمواجهه
غلاء الاسعار ومواجهه التضخم وايضا الدعوه
الى رفع رواتب الموظفين عندما تزداد اسعار
المواد الاساسيه من مواد غذائيه ووقود
وفواتير الغاز والكهرباء عندما ترتفع بما
بين 20 الى 40% وتبقى الاجور
والرواتب عند مستواها فهذا يستدعي تحركا
يقول مسؤول النقابات الرئيسيه وفيما يتعلق
بقانون رفع سن التقاعد يقولون ان مصادقه
المجلس الدستوري على بنوده الرئيسيه لا
يعني انه قانون عادل واننا سنواصل العمل
ضد هذا القانون بالمناسبه النقابات لم
تشكك بنزاهه المجلس الدستوري حساب اليسار
تحديدا على راسها حزب فرنسا العصيه
زعيم اقصى اليسار اعتبر ان المجلس
الدستوري من خلال قراره اثبت انه حريص على
حاجات الملكيه الرئاسيه ممثله بماكرون
اكثر من حرصه على حاجات الشعب السيد اللي
نفسه الملكيه الدستوريه تعبير يستعمله
زعيم اقصى اليسار للاشاره الى ان ماكرون
يحكمه كملك نايف اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل مدير مكتب
العربيه من باريس حسين غنيم شكرا لك اعلنت
وزاره الصحه في فلسطين مقتل طفل لم يكمل
18 ربيعا برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في
مخيم عقبه جبر جنوب اريحا وفق وزاره الصحه
فان عدد الاصابات بلغ سته اشخاص ثلاثه
منهم بحاله خطيره بعد اندلاع مواجهات اثر
اقتحام المخيم ومحاصرته ياتي هذا مع
مواصله القوات الاسرائيليه لليوم العاشر
تواليا اغلاق مداخل ومخارج مدينه اريحا من
بحث وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي مع
نظيره السوري فيصل المقداد الجهود
المبذوله لاطلاق دور عربي قيادي للتوصل
لحل سياسي للازمه السوريه ذكرت الخارجيه
الاردنيه ان لقاء الوزيرين شهد بحث عده
قضايا ثنائيه منها امن الحدود ومكافحه
تهريب المخدرات
هذا وتستضيف الاردن اجتماعي لوزراء خارجيه
كل من السعوديه والعراق ومصر وسوريا بهدف
التوصل لحل سياسي للازمه في دمشق وبحسب
ناطق الرسمي باسم الوزاره سنان المجالي
فان مبادره الاردن تهدف على بناء اتصالات
عربيه مع الحكومه السوريه ضمن الجهود
الراميه لانهاء ازمه سوريا وياتي هذا
اللقاء استكمالا للاجتماع التشاوري في جده
منتصف ابريل الماضي وكذلك قبيل القمه
العربيه المسمى عقدها في الرياض او في جده
في التاسع عشر من مايو الجهري
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مقتل
الزعيم المفترض لتنظيم داعش في سوريا خلال
عمليه نفذتها لاستخبارات التركيه وقال
اردوغان ان بلاده ستواصل عملها في محاربه
التنظيمات الارهابيه دون استثناء
اود ان اشارك الجمهور معلومات جديده خلال
هذا اللقاء هناك التطور يظهر معركه نصار
ضد التنظيمات الارهابيه الاستخبارات
التركيه كانت تتعقب منذ زمن طويل من يسمى
زعيم داعش المعروف بابو حسين القرشي وهذه
هي المره الاولى التي اعلن فيها هذا الخبر
خبر القضاء على هذا الشخص خلال عمليه
نفذها جهاز الاستخبارات التركي في سوريا
وسنواصل عملنا لمحاربه المنظمات الارهابيه
دون استثناء
مقاطع فيديو مشاهد للاعصار الذي ضرب ولايه
فلوريدا الامريكيه وتسبب بانقطاع الكهرباء
عن حوالي اربعه الاف شخص وكان من اكثر
المقاطع لفتا للانتباه ما نقله شهود عيان
ان احدى المركبات انقلبت وتحطمت على
الرصيف وتطاير ركامها امامهم
شكرا لكم على كرمه ولطف للمتابعه انتهت
هذه الساعه الاخباريه تغطيه العربيه
مستمره لاخبار السودان مع الزميله مدينه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات